we have a voicemail number which is 2192
David P
now I want to address the question asked
in this voicemail seriously because many
of you have been asking it take a listen
hey David Chris from Portland uh so you
know I really was hoping that you'd be
able to share with uh the listeners the
process that you go through to vet some
of these Republican candidates that you
have uh on your show that you're
interviewing because they almost seem so
consistently wacky yeah it's like you're
cherry picking them now I know you're
not but it seems like you are because
they're all just out there uh so if you
could explain the process that you go
through that'd be great as I mean that
person today Allison she really did say
it all yeah all right thanks bye so
listen many people have written in and
said David
why don't you interview the more
intelligent articulate and reasonable
Republicans running for 2022. why is
every person that you interview
completely whacked out of their gourd
here's the reality we cast an extremely
wide net very very wide net and I'm
looking now at emails from my colleague
John about all of the different people
that he approached it's dozens of
candidates dozens of candidates some of
them are more reasonable a couple weeks
ago I interviewed this guy Johnny Teague
who won the Republican primary in the
Texas Seventh District and he might
believe JFK Jr is still alive fine but
he he was more reasonable at least in
terms of some of his political views we
cast a really wide net most of these
Republicans don't want to be interviewed
by me I think many of them research us
and they look at past interviews I've
done and they turn us down I've also
told you that we've had probably five or
six who have initially agreed to be
interviewed and then something happens
between when they agree and the day of
the interview and they bail we literally
never hear from them again in many cases
they just they don't show up they're not
on Skype when we're supposed to be
interviewing them we never get an
explanation so some of them bail because
of that so what you are seeing is not me
cherry-picking the craziest Republican
candidates it's these are just the ones
that are ending up on the show for one
reason or another and some of them are
completely out of their minds like
Allison Hayden yesterday she was really
nuts scary scary nuts in a way on the
other hand we also have other candidates
who have just not shown up so we really
are trying to get a diverse
representation education of what is
going on on the Republican side right
now and listen Johnny Teague was more
reasonable Allison Hayden was more
Bonkers and you know John Gibbs was I
guess somewhere in between or something
like that but we are not cherry picking
and so many foot people you know
sometimes people say David why won't you
debate Ben Shapiro
I've had Ben Shapiro on and we've
invited him many times and he doesn't
accept coming on now you can say well
that's because your show isn't big
enough to be worth it for him fine but
don't tell me I'm unwilling you can't
say David you're unwilling
and then I explain he's welcome and then
you say well yeah why would he do your
show okay but the point was I'm willing
I'm willing that's the situation we're
not cherry-picking the crazies but I
think it Bears mentioning that a lot of
the Republicans running this year are
completely nuts
we have a great bonus show for you today
the British pound has plummeted to a
record low against the dollar we will
talk about the implications and the
reasons and more I am going to weigh in
on the chess
crisis wherein top player Magnus Carlson
has accused another player named Hans
Neiman of cheating it has taken the
Chess World by storm and we will talk
about it and also Brazilians are about
to vote
and there are viral election lies
there's a lot of trumpy stuff being said
by bolsonaro all of which we will talk
about on today's bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad yeah listen the bonus
show is great I would love for you to
sign up at joinpakman.com get access get
in there it's going to be an absolutely
fantastic thing we'll talk to you very
soon join pacman.com coupon code indict
gets you a discount